let's go next to
uh why don't we go now to Jet is it Jess
or Jesse from North Carolina it's kind
of cut off
uh Josiah as a matter of fact Josiah
welcome Josiah I appreciate it David hey
I got a question especially in light of
the last night's debate between Oz and
fetterman yes earlier this week right or
was it not last night well you know
we're it's Friday today it's Friday
today true touche uh I got thinking
about you know we're seeing obviously
the the polls change uh to the detriment
of Democrats you've been commenting on
this on your shows and I keep going back
to the double standards to which I feel
the Democrats are held to not just by
conservatives but also by Centrist
moderates and people on the left in
terms of performance and substance and I
was on Twitter and I was seeing like all
the headlines
um from people who would be considered
quote unquote uh liberal or mainstream
journalists which are perceived to have
a liberal bias and they were ravaging
fetterman for his performance even know
you know his communication issues as far
as we know are just it's temporary
Aphasia it's a stroke-induced speech
impediment yeah I don't know how
temporary it is to be totally honest but
it's not cognitive I mean he remembered
all the facts he remembered all the
points he understood his position and
those of Mehmet Oz I don't know if it's
temporary but it's certainly it's only a
speech thing that's absolutely the case
and fair enough it may it may very well
not be transient but I got thinking
about it and I'm like the GOP has been
fielding and successfully electing
terrible communicators who as far as we
know don't have a medical basis like W
bush and Palin and Trump and gosar and
green why is it that everybody not just
conservatives but everybody seems to
hold Democrats to a higher standard of
performance and style and substance in
terms of politicking and messaging and
debate and is there anything that we can
do as people who want Democrats to take
power to stop contributing to that
double standard I don't know what we can
do to stop contributing to it you know
you're asking me why because because
they're Hypocrites right I don't know
how to answer it anymore clearly you
know Herschel Walker as far as we know
didn't have a stroke it's not been
acknowledged that he has CTE from
playing football and he makes less sense
than fetterman right fetterman had a
speech issue but he at least
communicated policy and understands the
issues and stuck to the issue that was
being discussed etc etc they say
fettermen should have dropped out blah
blah
and they say any criticism of Herschel
Walker is racism for example or
something like that right I I don't know
what we can do to stop them being
Hypocrites but that's fundamentally what
this is do you agree though see because
I I guess I don't see it just as an US
versus them I feel that that people who
would nominally be considered quote
unquote liberal or quote unquote you
know like like there's the perception
that the the mainstream media that the
New York Times the CNN yeah has a
liberal bias and I probably agree that
most New York Times and CNN journalists
I would expect would vote Democrat but
they I feel hold Democrats to hire
performative and substantive standards
than Republicans as well because again
if if the metric is this person's a poor
Communicator therefore they should drop
out of the race then who on Earth could
the Republican party ever field the NW
Bush Palin Trump so so do you I guess do
you agree that it's not just
conservatives holding Democrats to a
higher standard I do agree I do agree
and part of it is I mean it's a good
thing that we have higher standards
right Trump would never have won the
Democratic Primary in 2016. he won the
Republican primary because we have
higher higher standards than they do and
that's a good thing in a lot of cases it
starts to become not so good if it
contributes to more of these right-wing
lunatics getting elected
I agree okay well I I appreciate it I'm
glad at least we there's some sort of
consensus and I appreciate your coverage
on all this keep going thank you so much
very much appreciate the call let's go
to Dylan from Tijuana Dylan welcome
foreign
can I tell you something that drives me
nuts about how Americans pronounce the
name of the of the city you're in
oh my God me too yeah they say oh you
know I went from San Diego to Tijuana
and I'm like first of all no where is
where are you getting some of these
additional syllables it doesn't make any
sense Tia like the word for aunt
um it's Tijuana that's it guys please
yeah I know all right Dylan go ahead
please I'm sorry
my uh my question for you is uh how
screwed do you think uh do you think
people are in the Colorado River Basin
like La Las Vegas Phoenix San Diego
Tijuana for water scarcity in the future
oh uh listen here's the thing about it
I don't want to okay let's see how can I
how can I back this up one of the things
that sometimes happens in any kind of
climate change discussion
is people will start to say Hey listen I
agree there's a problem I agree if
nothing changes it'll be a disaster but
I'm confident that engineering and
Ingenuity will figure out a solution
before it really becomes a problem and I
think that that's very very dangerous
thinking because we should be trying to
figure things out but we should also be
changing our behavior and our
consumption and all these different
things
on the issue of water
I actually am more confident that
science and technology is going to
figure out a solution in that part of
the country but I still think that water
usage and water rights which are a
really controversial thing in California
and in that area need to be kind of
rethought from the ground up anyway even
though based on what I'm reading about
water technology it's probably all going
to work out okay although there may be
irreversible changes to the fertility of
certain parts of those States as climate
changes and water becomes more scarce
not drinking water but but sort of
groundwater is as the the case may be so
that's that's a really complicated issue
yeah and here in Tijuana we've uh it's
happened a couple of times this year and
several times last year where we'll have
tens of thousands of people without
water because they're making repairs to
the to the water line supposedly
for you know better efficiency and you
know better management stuff like that
but
then I go out and drive in the streets
of Tijuana and there's just these large
leaks just you know roads are wet in the
middle of a sunny day because yeah
so uh I I as a consumer in General on
these climate change things I'm tired of
being blamed for my individual choices
when it's the large government
authorities and large industries that
are really really messing up it's like
the thing about straws you know and it's
like wait hold on a second let's back up
a little bit or you know I took a seven
instead of a five minute shower but look
at the almond and avocado Growers and
how they're you know using ungodly
amounts of water yeah no I totally know
what you mean the drops in the bucket
exactly right well yeah I really
appreciate you uh coming down coming
down to our side of the border and uh if
you're ever in Tijuana hit me up yeah so
like what are the what are the best
tacos in Tijuana
the tacos you're eating at the time oh
okay like they're all good they're all
good anyway yeah I will say one thing uh
in Tijuana we have a light Regional
variation on some uh Adobe
in Tijuana means something different
from the rest of the country the rest of
the country and the US will call it al
pastor but we have our own little kind
of twist Regional Twist on it so I
highly recommend Alabama that's that's a
fair recommendation have you had
Americans go down and and ask about
tacos have you heard that pronunciation
before
uh you just like asking the critters
don't you David yeah yeah yeah I've
heard everything yeah yeah no I re the
other day A friend of mine said tacos
and I was like what is happening yeah
anyway all right well thank you for the
call I appreciate it
all right let's take a very very short
break if you're holding
stay on because we're going right back
to the phones in a moment